reviens mais
belga
il chante avec un serveur puissante leur
amour pour jésus mais en face un plus
aux usa ils ont créé des communauté de
hippies convertis et scellement jusqu'en
europe leur entrée dans le monde du show
business qui peut choquer certaines
rames délicate ne doit cependant pas
faire oublier que ces enfants de dieu
c'est ainsi qu'ils ont choisi de se
nommer sont en fait de vrais petits
enfants du siècle un peu perdus dans
leur révolte
irritant parfois par trop de candeur
moustiques mais surtout hanté par l'idée
d'un monde plus juste et plus heureux
alors même s'ils font un tube
pourquoi ne pas leur accorder le
bénéfice du doute
voix
chaque fois qu'on aura compté beaucoup
de gens qui se moquent de ma première
avec sosthène nouveau qe 2 on sait que
l'amour de dieu existe et celui qui
change les que le fait qu'on soit 60 70
6 6 de tous les pays du monde il ya ya
un arabe il ya un juif qui vivent côte à
côte
on sait ce qui se passe dans le monde et
on sait pourquoi ça se passe et tant que
les hommes comprendront pas qu'ils ont
besoin de dieu et que tout ce que dieu
là on le sait l'amour tout ce qu'il a
pour eux c'est de l'amour
allez bien
hélas
il va aller
ap
mais anna
et un aveu dans
saisissez les révolutionnaires la façon
dont il a vécu avec ses dix exactement
la façon dont on vit maintenant et c'est
révolutionnaire est il celui qui change
les coeurs et items il vous aime tous a
levé on vous aime tous les jours par
exemple on chante dans la rue on chante
à quelques-uns quelques personnes
seulement maintenant que chanter à des
millions à travers le disque à travers
le spectacle et c'est ça qu'on veut
faire c'est notre révolution et c'est
comme si elle la vigne sur notre musique
on vous aime